下雨过后的屋檐果然是适合风铃
你从窗外看到风刚刚冒出嫩芽的声音很轻
而我决定了在猫的眼睛上旅行
于是乎所有的神秘都向后退
退成风景
只有隐藏的够灵巧的事情才能长成蒲公英
然后毫无负担地跟着前进
很小心
因为害怕
将只敢在梦中喜欢你的我的那部分吵醒
于是乎我默念了一首诗给你听
打开诗集的动作很轻很小心很轻很小心
就像猫跟风铃
我念了一首诗给你听
今天要分享的课程议题是电影与电视剧之创作
经验分享
同时分享那个区块哦
一个是电影的主题曲
一个是电视剧的主题曲
电视剧部分呢分享的主题曲创作是
武媚娘跟寝室皇妃
我们先分享的是寝室皇妃
寝室皇妃这首歌很特别特别在哪里呢
他的歌词非常非常的短
也就四段重复唱了之后我都没有重复写
因为那时候我觉得说这样子的画面感好像够了
所以创作是很弹性的
记得那因为这首歌很短
所以我可能一口气把它念完
然后再来讨论里面的创作技巧
你说倾城惹花凋谢
倾国羞红了明月
谁的美又伤了蝶
我只知道远方一声闷雷咒语敲打我的狼狈
快乐不起来的谁
午夜梦回这悠悠岁月
细数我的憔悴
寝室皇妃
我不要好累
乱世江山我不想了解你
在宫殿外听不见眼泪
看不见清水
寝室皇妃
我不要好累
这烽火狼烟语带威胁
被寂寞包围
我总是遇见离别
是不是很简短
而且某种程度很口语哦
他的所谓古风的词句
跟画面感的词汇没有那么的多
接下来解释一下为什么
因为这首歌拿到demo的时候
他的demo其实就很短
但demo短不代表实际配置的长度
因为有时候demo是把音乐走一遍而已
那通常走一遍之后拉到主歌再重复唱
然后唱完之后副歌再拉一遍再唱
所以一般的流行音乐通常都有三到4分钟
有时候还有5分钟
基本上不会超过5分钟或6分钟
多数的状况下介于三到4分钟
你要重复唱的段落
有时候一首歌的长度就看他重复唱的段落
有些人会这样子哦
主歌唱完副歌
然后再拉回去唱主歌
再唱副歌
然后最后再唱主歌
在副歌
副歌最后副歌再唱一遍
它的排列组合其实是很多元的
但不是说哪个排列组合好或不好
有时候主歌完之后直接接副歌
就一段主歌
副歌主歌副歌
然后副歌再唱一遍就结束了
那这次的作品为什么那么短呢
应该跟当时的创作环境有关
因为那时候在忙着一本新书
也就是韵脚师的第二集
然后那时候整个创作上很焦虑
就是你在写两个不同的题材
重视歌词的字数
很少可能几天就完成
然韵脚诗是一本书的量哦
他起码要四五十首的韵脚诗哦
你才可以堆叠成一本书常见的一个厚度
那时候就觉得哇怎么办
但是这个案子就觉得诶还不错
因为寝室皇妃的这个旋律也听过了
歌也不错
然后林心如唱的
所以那时候就觉得怎么办
创作的时候没有办法再写第二遍
自己的心里面的那道关卡过不去
好像自己偷懒的
当这种内心的变化跟挣扎
外面的人不晓得他只是这样说
哎你交出去的作品是他们要的
他们觉得诶还可以过得去
但是自己在演内心戏
就是两个我在辩论诶好像不够
要不要再加写一段
那可是时间上好像不允许
因为有个案子在推动
好像要截稿了
就自己在自己的辩论
后来呢有一方获胜呢
就是不需要再写第二段的这一方
为什么
因为我反复的听
好像这样子的意思就是够了
就是可以酝酿个戏剧的结构了
这个戏剧的铺陈有一些关键词汇已经用到了
因为里面的秦始皇妃是很累的
他面对了很多的压力
可能整个宫廷的对抗不谅解
外面的诸侯的觊觎他的位置
所以那时候就觉得啊好吧
就这样子的
后来我最终释怀的关键在于说
诶我创作这么多歌
为什么就不能有一首是短的呢
变成创作生涯上的一个类别
不要每个古风歌或所谓的中国风的歌
都是非常的冗长或篇幅
重唱的时候又注入新的意涵
就觉得不对
我竟然写了这么多首歌
四五百首的歌
为什么不能有一首歌
他只唱一遍demo
只唱一遍
我的歌词也跟着只走一遍就好了
所以最后的关键点在于说好吧
我想留下一个记录
就是古风歌曲从头到尾只唱一遍the demo
我一样歌词只写一遍坏
对方也觉得也可以
因为有时候意识不用经营的这么的繁琐
画面
有了歌词
有了故事
清楚了也就够了
接下来分享这部电视剧叫武媚娘传奇
然后他的歌名叫无字碑
因为当初去搜索歌名的时候
我就觉得无字碑很特别
因为无字碑是武则天他特地立下的
这块碑有多重
你知道吗
有98吨
他就在乾陵
他跟唐高宗李治合葬的一个皇室陵寝
而且乾陵很特别
它是古代皇室陵寝里面唯一大型的墓葬
没有被盗墓过的
你可以想象里面的殉葬品有多丰富
有多么的华丽
唐高宗李治在唐代最强盛的时候
跟武则天合葬的墓
所以呢有些人在揣测王羲之的兰亭集序
搞不好就在里面
当然了
历史上它曾经被盗墓过
可是没有一次成功盗墓的洞
可能挖到别的地方了
或是盗墓的时候突然下大雨大雷
那时候的人比较迷信
好像觉得被谴责了
被诅咒了就赶快撤退了
所以很幸运的是
乾陵至今没有被盗墓过
他的殉葬品之丰富
可以想象当初武则天为什么留下一个无字碑呢
他觉得他的功过应该由后人去记载
他自己不说
他自己去说自己有多伟大了
然后什么丰功伟业
他就觉得很矫情
所以这样子的一个唯一的女皇帝很特别
他就留下了一个巨型的无字碑
我就不为自己歌功颂德
我就很大气的留下一个无字碑
让后人去评断我的功过
所以这块碑让我留下很深的印象
我想说
既然她是武媚娘传奇的主题曲
那我应该取一个符号性最强的事物去象征
后来我选择了无字碑
那剧组方面也很喜欢
觉得啊无字碑很传神
总比你直接叫武媚娘传奇要好
接下来我们先进入主歌
一生漂泊摆渡
临岸却孤独问天地
向谁倾诉千载历史
我回顾恩怨情仇怎堪属帝王家终究是不归路
他的亮眼的词句应该是最后一句
帝王家终究是不归路
玄武兵变沧桑
马蹄声声乱
这祸起萧墙
不忍看深闺漫长
谁轻叹
恩怨情仇
我独伤
我到底守的是谁的江山
这句话也是整段歌词的经典
因为唐代是李家的江山
那武媚娘就是因缘际会当上了皇帝
女皇帝
但是他觉得说
她终究还会把政权还给李家的后代
所以我这么辛辛苦苦捍卫了你们的政权
但是我守的是谁的江山呢
不是我武家的
是你们李家的
接下来我们进入副歌
无言立下无字碑
眼带着泪
当初那个轻唤媚娘的谁是我永世的霜雪
武则天尽管是不可一世的皇帝
但是他戏里面的小角落还是属于女人的气质
然后换他媚娘的就是唐高宗李治
他的小名再来是不舍得一切
甚至是大唐
我退位心无悔
武则天他把政权还给李家
他其实没有太多的悔恨
因为一个人到了那样子的巅峰
基本上他的追求已经没有了
所有荣华富贵
所有世界上该享受的位置他都有了
所以他那时候心里面的心态
其实是回到武媚娘的角色
第二遍的副歌
无言立无字碑
眼带泪
功
过随人是非
我无愧史册
任由他写下
不求谅解
如真能再世轮回
愿来生落户山水寻常布衣家
有你陪
这个你就是唐高宗平凡的心碎
爱过谁
可以重新的选择他
宁愿他就是寻常布衣一般的百姓
有个守着她的男人
然后很平凡的心碎
因为旁边有一个人在陪着她
所以这个是武媚娘的心境的变化
因为当初这样子写的话
会觉得说这样子比较贴近真实的人性
大家只会看到武则天内开玩笑女皇帝耶
所以大家觉得说哇她应该是那种很强势
紧握着权力不放的人
谁知道她心里面有个小角落是给武媚娘的
如果有来世可以选择
他宁愿不要生在帝王家
宁愿出生在寻常的布衣家
然后平凡的心碎
有一个深爱他的人陪就够了
这是心境的转换
所以那时候去创作的时候
就觉得诶这样子比较贴近人性真实的一面
最后的结尾就是呼应第一大段的最后一行
帝王家终究是不归路
所以如果有选择
他宁愿来生落户山水寻常布衣家
有你陪
这样子词句上的前后呼应
会让故事线的结构性更强
接下来分享的是电影主题曲的部分叫十里桃花
这个电影的前身有个电视剧
电视剧叫三生三世十里桃花
但是我写的不是电视剧的主题曲
而是电影
其实写电影的主题曲
跟电视剧或者是电网很不一样
因为电玩大家一直在玩
然后他的那种好像是歌词的生命力比较久
然后电视剧起码二三十集
四五十集
然后网络上也可以观看
得到重复的观看
但是电影呢有时候比较短
就可能电影上映有个话题之后
就没有再重复出现的一个频率了
但是就是有点小小的可惜
就是一样是一个创作的作品
为戏剧而服务
但是跟电视剧跟电影相比的话
感觉上总觉得电视剧的主题曲
它的生命周期会比较长
a one呢我一开始呢又用了我惯常使用的方法
就是一有没有一一又拿来用了
好一笔一轻叹一行一惆怅
故事等莫甘
却等来心伤
从此缘分模糊了
纸上少了300年前的那几张
这样子的创作其实就有个故事背景的啦
因为他给我故事大纲
而且那个电视剧之前就演过了
接下来看笔锋
几道弯
前世千百转
很明显吧
千百转去对仗几道弯
尘云细云端
九重天上产
无奈过往三生石上断人间纷乱无怨夜阑珊
恨梦太短
这里面的三生石跟九重天跟戏剧的结构有关
因为它是一个架空的历史
有时候一些古装片
历史片有时候是架空的
像这个三生三世十里桃花
它是架空的
所以架空的历史是真实的
历史上没有这样子的一个朝代或者是故事内容
接下来我们分享的是副歌的段落
十里断桃花
伤爱飘落在何方
这个十里就是呼应他的十里桃花的歌的名字
而且他电视剧里面也是三生三世十里桃花
我只为你绽放世间最美的模样
下一句副歌
十几段桃花殇
为你佛前拈香
求三生三世都与你成双
这样的一个词义的结构呢
其实呼应戏剧的一个主轴
就是三生三世这个词汇创作的时候
其实我们都有一些要求
只要铺垫的合理
都是创作的一种技巧
不要说对方要求的关键字哇
好奇怪啊
不晓得放在哪里
那就证明你的能力不够
你的技术不行
应该是专业的作词者
不要怕被要求
应该是说你有能力面对任何的要求或者是限制
这样子才是有专业水平的一种呈现
今天跟大家分享的是
关于电视剧主题曲与电影主题曲的创作
其实电影主题曲写的还蛮多的
像之前那个不能说的秘密
还有长城
还有满城尽带黄金甲
其实非常多
但有些歌词之前有介绍过了
所以就没有把它集中在这个环节里面
跟大家分享
像这样的一个专案的执行
通常需要具备几个条件
一个有很明确的要求
或者是说条件
这是有丰富相对应的资料
可以供收集或者是参考
接下来就是个记忆点的摸索
所有的记忆点就是歌词的副歌
有时候你摸索歌词的副歌是最困难的
那最困难的事物呢
我建议各位同学
如果将来有这样子的可能或合作案先解
解决副歌最困难的记忆点先去找
否则呢有时候遇到这种状况
你费尽心力的去铺垫a one a two的主歌哇
整个铺垫的歌词的结构你很满意
然后语音也很顺畅
到了副歌卡住了哇
写不出来
那我告诉你
这样子的作品是不及格的
因为最核心的语词应该用在副歌
所以呢之前的课堂上
有经过同学们的多数的状态下
把最漂亮最有记忆点的词句留给副歌使用
也因此通常我在写歌手专辑的时候
我不见得副歌开始写
因为歌手专辑的聚焦性跟要求性
没有那么的鲜明
有时候可能想到了主歌画面感就先写
有时候写完A柱了再写v one副歌
有时候副歌写完再回去
主歌开始写
就是创作上不会太有一个节奏感
那种节奏感就是一定副歌先出来才写主歌
记得我的建议
我的建议来自于经验的累积
像这样子的影视合作案
不管是电影
电视或是电玩这样子的一个搭配
通常我都会全力的去经营副歌的基点
跟歌迷集中火力去发展
因为它的针对性会比较强
但是呢一般歌手的专辑就不需要
一般歌手的专辑
并不是你这首歌来当专辑的主题
不至于
所以呢一般歌手的创作会比较自由度
或搭配性比较多元
就是你可能先发展a one a two
a one b two或者副歌写一段
再去经营前面的主歌
或者回来写副歌的第二段都可以
只是比较聚焦式的合作案
通常我的创作顺序就很明显
就是全部的精力去进攻他的核心价值
就是副歌的基点跟歌的名字